hello I'm neuronal I'm here in our CBS
this morning Toyota greenroom with
writer producer and director now
Scoville she's worked on iconic shows
like The Simpsons Late Night with David
Letterman Murphy Brown NCIS The Muppets
coach and Sabrina the Teenage Witch
which he created and executive produced
now good morning good morning he's so
much for joining us I'm so happy
I've we've spoken before but never I
know and this is your first first book
first solo book or solo book that's
right just the funny parts I mean I look
at that I'm like how hard is it to come
up with a book title well this one was
actually given to me by one of my
mentors a guy named Barry Kemp and five
years ago were at lunch in the universal
commissary and I said you know I'm
thinking of writing a memoir and he went
you should call it just the funny parts
and I know a good pitch when I hear it
so that's stuck in I did I did think of
calling it just the angry and bitter
parts that's like an eighth volume set
yeah probably would not sell it as well
as just the funny parts but it's not
just the funny parts in the book you
share a lot of details I I do and and
you know Hollywood is tough on everyone
but I think it is especially tough on
women and people of color how so how did
you find it was tough well you know we
there's now the whole meat to movement
but you know that's historically been
part of Hollywood and in fact it's so
codified it even has a cute nickname the
casting couch which does some better
than the sexual harassment sofa right
but you know this was accepted for so
many years it's just the way it was and
I mean you're talking about - not just
in front of the camera right but behind
the camera and writing I mean there's so
few women in comedy and so few men
writing for comedy especially in
late-night TV which is where this all
began so in 2009 David Letterman goes on
camera and says I've had sex with women
I've worked with
and anyone who worked on the show was
not surprised by this and there was a
lot of talk about whether what he did
was right or wrong and I had worked on
the show I was the second woman ever to
write for Letterman and I had some
inside information mm-hmm so I spoke up
at that time and then pivoted to the
gender discrimination in the writers
room I described what kind of boss David
Letterman was well he it's a hierarchy
and he's the king and everybody wants to
please the King and they have done
studies where corporations that are
hierarchical do have more harassment and
abuse you know because the power is so
concentrated at the top but you
described some pretty interesting things
in the book about the way David
Letterman not only treated women but all
of his writers and staff right right
well when I was there he had this quirk
where he would only speak to the head
writer on his car phone because this is
pre-sell phone but we did have phones
just in cars so you would you'd have to
wait for those younger younger viewers
not there remember the car phone like
you were really cool if you had the car
phone yeah no that's huge so he we would
sit in the writers room watch him leave
and then ten minutes later the head
writer would say I'm gonna go call him I
also tell the story about how he was you
know look this is like the funniest guy
on television and he never enjoyed the
process he never thought he did a good
show and in fact after one show he lined
up all the producers and he told them to
take a swing at him and he made them
punch him and I I described it in the
book as it's this twist on the bully as
he's the bully who makes you punch him
yeah and and how was Garry Shandling
influential oh well there's this HBO
documentary that's wonderful about him
so I write my first spec script for TV
the most popular show in America at the
time is The Cosby Show
but I wrote for my favorite show which
was it's Garry Shandling show which was
the pre Larry Sanders show that Garry
did and amazingly they bought it which
is like you're a rookie who gets a home
run yeah in your first at-bat and I go
to LA to get my notes and the first
thing Gary says to me is you write like
a guide but that was like a positive
complement human yeah but what's
interesting and this only occurred to me
years later you know Gary was very raw
about his own relationships he was very
insecure about his looks in his stage
routine and it occurred to me he waits
like a girl and I mean that that's a
compliment right and what do you mean
that he writes like a girl well there's
choice of the things he wrote he wrote
about the jokes he wrote were often
relationship jokes and how's my hair and
things we would think we're
stereotypically female you've been doing
this now for three decades
yes and you write about your successes
and also your failures but your personal
motto
I like your personal motto which is
write that which doesn't kill me always
allows me to regroup and retaliate yes I
get the regroup
but the retaliate well yeah you know we
I worked on Lena and with Sheryl
Sandberg and we always joked that if I
had written it alone it would have been
called barge in would've read it not
lean in that's funny yeah so I don't
know I think you know you you I have a
thick skin I had this wonderful
supportive mother there's story in the
book about how she went to my third
grade parent-teacher conference and the
teacher said now makes too many jokes in
class could you ask her to tone it down
so my mom delivers this message on my
40th birthday I love your mom for that
No and what does your mom say about that
why she didn't tell you at the time
because she thought no this is what
makes my daughter special that's exactly
right and and yeah she wasn't gonna take
notes on my personality from my teacher
yeah and so what did you think when your
mom told you that it at at age 40 well I
just thought you know I've wondered how
did I escape this cultural bias for
twenty women yeah and you know there
were on one hand I had this mother who
was protecting me and I had two
hilarious aunts and they were the center
of attention at every party they were
very they had a very dark sense of humor
one day my sister Alice was reading
Little Women on the sofa and my aunt
pinkie walked by tapped her on the
shoulder and said don't get too attached
to Beth so it wasn't self-deprecating it
was and you knew it in many ways to not
only because your family was very funny
there was right yeah but also you know I
grew up with Carol Burnett
I grew us Joan Rivers was hosting the
Tonight Show mm-hmm and I thought she
was funnier than Johnny Carson yeah and
you know if you were born after 1970 you
didn't see a female hosting one of the
big three Network nightly talk shows
right then you went to Harvard yes and
then what did you how did you break into
comedy writing well I was a sports
writer first and globe yeah
yeah and I think the reason you went to
Vanity Fair right right but I was drawn
to sports writing because it's a less
serious part of the paper and it's also
emotional I mean think about it it's the
rate sports thrill of victory and the
agony of defeat right so I was drawn to
that and then one day I bump into a
friend who's an editor and she said to
me I don't mean this as an insult but I
think you could write for television and
on she's actually really hard to write
for television general but writing for
television too because it's more for the
ear right right it's it's
dialogue-driven it's character-driven
but I liked it there's a lot of
psychology in it really trying to get
inside someone's head whether that's you
know Homer Simpson Miss Piggy or
President Obama Yeah right and you've
written the jokes for President Obama
for the White House Correspondents
Association that's different too I feel
like writing for them I mean not only
writing jokes for a stand-up like that
not just the show right but for the
President of the United States
well what's fun is when you write a joke
for the president it it shows up on the
front page in the newspaper and that
doesn't happen when you're on a sitcom
but he's really funny and I'm looking
for a line I mean I I mean think about
all the people you've written lines for
sometimes it's dependent on the I mean
certainly some may fall flat just on the
performance right actor well I've been
very lucky though because I've worked
with you know Bob Newhart and Caroline
Rhea and Andy Samberg and you know it's
like playing tennis with with you know
Williams I'm Nina Williams yeah yeah and
and with Serena Williams and if you just
get your servant
you know don't they'll do the rest for
the wind so how did you end up after all
this working with Sheryl Sandberg well
we met through Facebook so I wrote this
I write this piece in 2009 that's about
gender discrimination in late-night TV
and I kind of came out of the closet as
a feminist and she does her TED talk in
2010 which is amazing why we have so few
women leaders and in 2011 a mutual
friend through Facebook writes to me and
says have you seen Cheryl's TED talk and
I write back seen it I memorized it aha
so he put us together and she was just
starting to really ramp up her public
profile and I was very happy to be there
and help I mean because the book is not
a funny book meaning lean in only men
yeah it's a I hope
it's entertaining in its own I mean it's
a great read but in many ways too and
now it's been more than five years yeah
four million copies four million copies
that's right you know it's a disturbing
kind of look at some way about the lack
of advancement women yeah where they
should be well I think one of the
benefits of the book is women supporting
other women I feel like we've made this
huge leap in the past five years you
sure made it cool for women to support
other women it used to be this duty but
you know Madeleine Albright's same as
you know there's a special place in hell
and I actually say in my book that there
should be a special cloud in heaven for
women who do you help other women
because if sometimes it felt like a
burden and now I think women are really
feeling like the rising tide lifts all
boats well I hope I make it to that
special place and having me thank you
and congratulations on your own or yeah
congratulations